You talked about ALKP. That's an acronym for alkaline phosphatase. I was in the blood
work last week. I got my blood work back in 9 August. First, my alkaline phosphatase was 90,
went up to 115 October 24. Still fighting lots of body aches. Long COVID, we're walking
to the pneumonia. I don't know. Using clear enzyme just does not cut the pain. Ordered some
unteroish, too. Just use it last night and help some of my body just aches, especially
by legs. Okay, so if the alkaline phosphatase is raised because of liver congestion, that's
one thing. So we don't know that exactly. But to support that, you could think of using
a hot pack of beer liver, doing coffee enemas, doing castor oil packs over your liver. If
the alkaline phosphatase is raised because there's retastasis to the bone and there's
only lytic erosion of the bone. That's a totally different story. It might be helped with
using direct EEG-CG, which can help to decrease the inflammatory process that's going on at the
bone. But addressing that is important, too. That the pain and the body aches kind of concerns me.
I don't remember who asked this question, but if you don't know that you have any metastasis or
you hadn't confirmed that that isn't the problem, then it's confirmed that you have no
bone metastasis in the alkaline phosphatase is raised just raising just because of the liver
or liver congestion. Where is something else going under the liver? I stick to the suggestions
that I gave. If you know that you have only metastasis, and that's the reason for the
alkaline phosphatase rising, then the clear inflame will help with that, too, but that wouldn't be my
first choice for the pain. I would also make sure in your blood work to look and see if you have
elevated blood calcium levels. That's another hint that there's some lytic function going out. If
your blood calcium level is even at the high end of the normal, it wasn't, it was within the middle
of the range. In the previous test, that would be another hint that it's caused from an elevation
of the bony lytic growth. So you want to make sure that you're addressing that in some way, too.
That can give you pain in your legs also. Also, pain in your legs can't be caused from an
ebius, so make sure you look at your CBC as well. Because higher deficiency can be causing that, too.
Well, this is a second part of the question. What else could I do to provide red blood cell coat?
Well, let's tell you this first acid ebius, that can be causing for your legs.
And you may need to be taking iron. If you do take iron, make sure you add
Ardemisidin as well. So if you have Ardemisidin at home, I will take capsule of Ardemisidin
with iron. Just take a good type of chelated iron.
Now, with that prescription iron, that would be very salty, which is hard on your gut,
so our clear iron or there's some other good iron products out there.
Most reputable nutritional companies have a good source of iron, but you do want to take it with
an Ardemisidin. Now, the way is that you can do to get your red blood cell coat up as
eating beets and eating red meat and things like that that is going to have the b vitamins in it as well.
And like I said before, b vitamins.